[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monfils joue un peu plus
juteuses
vous avez vos envies mes clients selon
le sondage de satisfaction
des clients sur son âge de satisfaction
combien vous ont mis un
combien les clients vous ont mis sur le
sondage de satisfaction vous avez vu
combien vous habiller comme notre
sondage de satisfaction je parle pas
français ou quoi oui à
l'heure
23h15 c'est pas la cession ou m'avait
remplacé parce que ne vais pas ferran 6
me
vous en ferez du relâchement dans l'air
écoutez moi bien oui de zenit je crois
pacs
à tout à l'heure
il était tout s'est passé c'est quoi ce
n'est pas l'existence de ce contrat dont
je savais avant de
mourir oui mais madame ce n'est pas
qu'une capote
[Applaudissements]
si vous allez craquer
m
mike tomlin
on
roy
vous irez
elle explique tout
[Musique]